dans tout le monde alors maintenant on
va s'attaquer à un nouveau joueur
donc on avait fait philidor dans les
premières vidéos et maintenant on va
parler de la bourdonnais alors ce joueur
que louis chamaillent de la bourdonnais
a été déjà deux meilleurs joueurs
français on va dire du début du 19e
siècle et est sûrement même le meilleur
joueur du monde
parce que en fait en 1930 en 1834 par
dont il a joué un gros match contre le
meilleur joueur britannique inquiète à
néerlandais mcdon m&i un match qui était
très long en fait on fait de faire une
mini match entre juin et octobre en 1834
voilà donc mcdonnell juste le meilleur
joueur britannique dont il était un
mandat comme je les dis et labourdonnais
à lui clairement meilleurs joueurs
français donc comme philidor et je vais
au café de la régence depuis longtemps
et il battait tout le monde donc été
vite proclamé meilleur joueur français
et il ya eu ce match là qui servira plus
tard en fait en gros deux modèles pour
définir le type de titre mondial
parce qu'on sait maintenant qu'on fait
des matches un petit deux championnats
du monde comme là on va avoir de carlson
caruana il tiendrait plein simple
t-shirt parce qu'il est magique kharkov
kasparov et c est donc même si ce match
là n'est pas le titre officiel de
décerner donc le titre de champion de
champion du monde
quand même le vainqueur pouvait être vu
comme le meilleur joueur du moment
voilà donc c'est un match
qui était remporté par par la
bourdonnais 45 victoires à 27 13 parties
nulles voilà et et voilà donc on va
regarder un peu comme enfoncé ce pas ce
à quoi
du coup là je le montrais la quatrième
partie du match parce que oui à l'époque
en gros les parties nulles ils les
comptes et par c'est à dire que le match
a été a été débuté là bordeaux n'avait
les blancs mcdonnell les noirs il est
nul à la première dont mathieu rejouer
avec les blancs au nul troisième run une
4e route c'est toujours la première
partie du match quelque part mais
c'était déjà la quatrième allez c'est
parti donc là bordeaux n'est que l'encan
sport 4 5 cavaliers trois cavaliers c6
et poussé quatre une italienne fossé 5
ils jouent ces trois donc on va en
comprendre les blancs veulent prendre le
centre avec des 4 et mcdonald's joue
je vous des six alors s'arrêter c'est
préférable à un moment ça de jouer
cavalier m6 pour contre attaquer le pion
aux 4 et sur des quatre ont fait prise
prisée tous les quatre et chaque bon ça
seul atelier plus plu actuel mais ok sur
cette fois il a fait des six du coq et
blanc les jeunes pas il fait des 4 puis
on prend tu comprends b6 et la
bourdonnais joue des cinq ici alors
éventuellement dans d'autres options je
pense un peu comme cali c3 de
développement voire même le coup h3 pour
ne pas laisser le souvenir angers 4
cloud et parce qu'en fait ce qu loi je
viendrai mettre la pression sur surtout
en d4 puisque les dans la taille déjà
deux fois donc en 23 ans se défendre et
bien d'autres centres et ça serait
intéressant que j'ai aussi comme ça
m'est donc des cinq se veut plus
agressif en attaque le cavalier et on
pose une question on a donc les langes
qui a valu aux 5
à noter que plus tard dans le match et
voilà une position et un mcdonald's à
jouer qui lisent ces recettes qui en
fait un coût raisonnable
pourquoi pas le câblier va bien j'ai six
l'autre kavanagh raid 6 et les noirs aux
rockets donc c'est complètement jouable
par contre une grosse erreur ce serait
de jouer cavalier à 5 parce que même si
on attaque le fou en fait les blancs
peuvent juste le retirer et je veux
ensuite b4 et un frette lequel il ya 5
va se retrouver à trappes et ne pourra
pas sauver de la vous passerez très gras
front mais oui cabello cinq dons qu'il a
pris je comprends qu'ils avaient laissé
trois cavaliers et 6 rouges et 5 petit
rock dont jusque là rien de particulier
d'un f3 via mettre la pression sur axis
et avec les nourrissent des clubs comme
des six est donc avec les blancs ils
décident de venir admirer la structure
adverse en doublant les pions mais il
sait de la paire de fou et l'a donc il
une idée assez intéressante alors même
si tout n'est pas parfait mais c'est pas
mal comme le concept il joue g4 et c'est
bien jouer pourquoi parce qu'en fait il
veut fixer les pions noirs doublé sur la
colonne f ne pas laisser l'opportunité
au nord de f5 surtout et d'ouvrir le jeu
pour la paire de fou donc à noter une
structure g4 emprise mais n'est pas
prenable puisqu'après fou prend il ya
simplement tour g1 créer cette enfilade
là le clouage et s'il le faut et défend
dur juste l'attaqué une fois de plus et
et les blancs galine qu'est ce donc
mcdonald's en panne sur l'un des
panneaux et il fait froid g7
il veut faire une tentative de contre
attaques rapides à lectoure h 8 et h5
à noter bien sûr que le coup peut-être
que mucha schwyz serait sera également
jouable mais mais pourquoi qu'avait lieu
de tes joues et tu auras jeu suit tour
g1 avec huit tours j'ai 2 donc l'idée
est multiple et mediaset défendre de
kiev 2 pour remettre au roi de venir en
aide aux autres facs en vrac comme ça il
peut lâcher à de protection du pion qui
attaqué par par le foulée 6 pour
l'instant et deuxième idée si une fois
qu'on aura rockets ou quoi la tour pour
l'autre tour pour venir en vient au
droit d'oublier toile monacology donc
pas mal recette a été jouée bon à noter
bien sûr que h5 du sud sera également
envisageable point noir pour le set
grand roque et h5 donc là c'est bien
joué en fin de ce que fait ce que ça mc
donald ac et noir il cherche le fils du
contre eux je avoir la position pour ces
fous et
voilà c'est pas mal il a fait il a fait
g5 et là ça rend critique
il a choisi de pousser pourquoi pas mais
à vrai dire la prise peuvent être
pouvaient être joués même c'était plutôt
bien joué
pourquoi vous saper tout reprend
maintenant plus personne défense pions
donc on peut le prendre au passage on
menace le retour ans le 3 pour faire une
enfilade double attaque sur le rang et
la tour donc attention et ya noté bien
sûr que les banques pourraient pas
prendre cette option de cinq ans même si
un échec et noir font re f6 est en fait
la tour ayant fermé on a plus de cases
de suite là ont débloqué par nos propres
pions f5 vous défendez pas fou c'est 8
leroy sur laquelle j 5
et tous ces cases l'aller sur son
président donc donc ça c'était une jolie
variantes et du coup sûr faux problème 2
bat fallait pas faire trop prendre 5 km
il faut trois qu'on a dit et peut-être
c'est un peu comme tour g7 mais bon
après avoir fui la tour doit repartir
miller s'en vont et les noirs et gagnez
un pion donc position plus avantageuse
pour les noirs
voilà bon il a raté quelque chose dans
cette variante est il a joué ça ok bon
et c3 défend le centre fossé cinq bons 5
pourquoi peut-être qu'ils avaient peur
un peu d'un coup comme des sinistres
kerry qui vient quelque chose comme ça
donc ok j'ai six bombes avec les blancs
c'est bien il c'est d'ouvrir d'ouvrir le
jeu à leur droite vers s'ouvrir la
colonne j'ai prise prises et continuera
la position avec 4 très intéressant même
si à première vue le coup tout des g1
serait assez logique simplon ont doublé
tour sur la colonne ouverte on veut
rentrer c'est bon charmant sûrement un
choix logique et bien mais être 4 ça
peut se comprendre si l'on veut faire
sauter tous et amath pion central et est
bien sûr l'objectif passé le roi noir
qui va se retrouver seul et après donc
f4 il ya eu puis on prend il a doublé
les toits maintenant et est roi et
fuites anticipe pour g7 alors peut-être
que le mieux c'est être tenté un coup
comme f3 quand même pour peut-être un
pion depuis sa lancée pour faire du
contre jeu et c'est une option de
défense ces thèmes sont pas mal bon il à
faire avec huit tours g6 maintenant f3
donc une petite diversion
puis on prend avec 5 et il a sûrement la
faute fatale pour mcdonald's parce que
là en fait même si le roi noir est un
peu dans les cordes
finalement il n'y a rien de dramatique
et il aurait pu tenter de faire c'est
fou 17 avec l'idée de faire ensuite
floue 8 pour peut chasser cette tour et
reprendre le contrôle de certaines cases
évidemment à noter qu'on peut pas
prendre ce pion viatour échec
un double attaque voilà mais ce qu'il a
fait dans la partie c'est fou et 5
à première vue paraître contrôle des
cases ici qu'il est importante mais là
un bon coup joué par part de la
bourdonnais je vais vous laisser
chercher sous le mettre en pause c'est 5
ou acquis bas qui veut lui permettre
d'organiser partir allez on y va
c'est le coût des six sacrifice de pions
mais ça fait deux choses ça délivre ce
fou qui veut voir je vois que son rôle
soit des banales et de deux le cavaly
éventuellement aussi la casse des saint
araille options prendre tous les chèques
non je mange trois sets carrés et des 5
ghz 'sera 17 et fourbe et 5 soit donc
joli tableau de match final on voit
toutes les pièces blanches vous
complètement leur rôle la tour sur le 8e
ranger le fou qui livre le mat
lecavalier qui tient ainsi deux cases
ici et le pion la case de 6
mais la partie intéressante bonne prise
d'initiative ma part de la branche donna
le coup j'ai quatre intéressant mais yu
combat du combat et ça a pu tourner
différemment
donc voilà ça c'était la première
victoire en avant dit steve du match on
reviendra sur d'autres partis ensuite
parce que c'était intéressant pas être
humain comme match voilà
à bientôt